nous accueillons aujourd'hui andré gagné
professeur au département d'études
théologiques à l'université concordia à
montréal
bonjour ne s'est gagnée bonjour monsieur
gagné vous êtes l'auteur d'un essai qui
colle à l'actualité internationale avec
les élections aux états unis qui auront
lieu mardi prochain soit le 3 novembre
il s'agit de votre livre ces
évangéliques derrière trompe
or première question qui vient à
l'esprit monsieur gagné pourquoi ce
livre vous savez ce lit tombe à point en
fait ce livret + même été écrit un peu
avant parce que les évangéliques qui
soutiendront ont eu un rôle très très
significatif en 2016
ils sont enfin crédit et pour la
victoire du président américain
car ils ont voté à 80 1% d'évangéliques
landi point le guen ou nés de nouveau
qui ont accordé leur appui au président
vous savez cet appui de marc encore une
fois très très solide car il y en eut un
sondage très décent la mi octobre de
cette année qui encore une fois donné
les évangéliques
l'un a une forte proportion pour
reconduire dans nos 30 à un second
mandat
il serait autour de 78 % à vouloir
soutenir le président arménien pour un
deuxième mandat
monsieur entre gagner pouvez vous nous
définir ces kiss et évangéliste ont il
ya tout un spectre dont pouvez vous nous
définir c'est qui spécifiquement ce qui
est qu'ils soutiendront vous savez aux
états unis il y a les statistiques pour
2020 selon eux il y a aux etats unis à
environ 110
il ya évangélique ça ça inclut toutes
sortes de dénomination parce que
l'évangéliste c'est quelque chose c'est
une et bühler qui est assez complexe
mon bouquin en particulier s'intéresse à
une frange rouge de l'évangélisme
américain pour elle les néo
charismatique coccyx et par nice et 110
millions il constitue environ 41,2
milliards de ceux de ce groupe
d'évangile
ils sont un groupe important parce que
plusieurs des acteurs près du pouvoir
mériter ça donne à ses idées qu'on
appelle ici des charismatiques ou six
ans amy justement sur les charismes de
l'esprit la personne de l'est le sein ou
au sein de la vie chrétienne et ils sont
une mouvance musique hâtivement
probablement lorsqu'on parle de lion
quelle expertise en crise à travers le
monde il ya toutes dénominations
confondues 645 millions d'adhérents à
des amendes en deux et commence exercé
comme ans exercent leur influence sur la
politique américaine et comment ils sont
impliqués dans la politique américaine
en fait ils ont depuis plusieurs années
adopté ce qu'on appelle une théologie du
pouvoir politique certains d'entre eux
moyens surtout ceux qui soutiennent
jaune parce qu'il faut dire d'emblée que
ce ne sont pas tous les ai mangés les
nécessairement qu'il soutient john
messieurs qui le soutiennent certaines
certains hommes s'adonnent à ce qu'on
appelle le 2 mignoni sme c'est une
idéologie politique qui voit que les
croyants les chrétiens sont appelés à
exercer leur autorité sur tous les pans
de la société de prendre contrôle des
institutions culturelles sociales et
politiques afin d' un certain sens veut
faire advenir ce qu'ils appellent le
royaume de
c'est une forme de d g monica et il
envisage pour l'amérique
et bien sûr ça c'est l'idée ou la
théologie politique du courant mais ils
ont développé une stratégie de
mobilisation intéressante que je détail
dans le livre qu'on appelle le mandat de
cette montagne de la culture où ils
encouragent les croyants à unicredit
sphères culturelles des français sociale
des stars telles que l'éducation les
arts et les médias la politique
l'économie la famille le monde religieux
est ici de suite afin de gravir les
échelons de ce sport culturel pour
finalement devenir des individus
d'influentes pour transformer
essentiellement la société à travers
c'est doré fluence munger ans et un
rhume chez stratégie qu'ils ont
développée avec la et sk un risque sur
la démocratie américaine avec ce schéma
de fonctionnement cette volonté
d'instaurer le royaume de dieu
absolument
la question des sommes que les chrétiens
ne devrait pas s'impliquer en politique
comme ce n'est pas le but du livre et ce
n'est pas l'orientation qu'on donne ou
qu'on croit mais plutôt ces groupes on
bien sûr une visée qui est profondément
anti pluraliste et qui dans un certain
sens s'éloigne des principes qu'on
adhère lorsqu'on fait partie de
démocratie libérale
ils vont tout de même utiliser les
leviers de la démocratie pour pour se
mettre en place
sur le plan politique mais en utilisant
celle de la démocratie
alliant à
à qui le pouvoir politique ce sera pour
mieux le subvertir ce sera pour mieux
subvertir la démocratie est finalement
contrecarrer le pluralisme des idées et
des valeurs
est ce que le système américain n'est
pas immunisé contre un tel scénario
d'une hégémonie surnom parce que on peut
se servir de la démocratie ainsi il y as
suffisamment d'électeurs qui adhèrent à
ces idées il est possible justement
d'avoir des gens dans des positions
politiques et des influences sociales
qui vont justement mettre en place les
conditions nécessaires pour faire en
sorte qu'une telle hégémonie puisse
s'instaurer
on peut se servir de la démocratie c'est
pour cela qu'il refuse l'étiquette âge
de démocrates en lui disant non nous ne
sommes pas tes os 4 mais en même temps
on peut se servir la démocratie placer
des gens en position se protéger pour
finalement faire sauter la démo grèce
écoutez est ce que la question de base
est plus président américain ni les
évangéliques ou est ce qu'il est il
utilise ils utilisent leur a pris c'est
quoi sa relation avec cette nuance c'est
intéressant comme question et c'est une
question qui revient souvent
vous savez il y à moins d'une semaine le
président américain s'est déclaré comme
étant un chrétien non d'ennemis
nationale
on sait les roms et était auparavant à
l'hystérie et non pratiquants mais la
menace est déclarée chrétiens non des
mamies nationale est ce qu'elle est
venue de ces gros oui bah a précédé
c'est l'incroyable cdi glisser les
mouvances et une ccc des critiques qui
n'ont pas nécessairement de structure
de redevabilité sur le plan de la
gouvernance en cdi c'est souvent des
entités des églises indépendantes de
structures de redevabilité ecclésiale et
ce qui est étonnant c'est que secretin
ont ils omis nationale sont pour la
grande majorité responsable du vote
électoral en faveur de notre enfant de
lui voyez vous et c'est une mouvance
très significative aux états unis en ce
moment dans notre époque et c'est
difficile de savoir est il vraiment du
chrétien évangélique
vous savez ceux qui ne le soutiennent
pas parmi les évangéliques bon vous dire
que non john ne reflète pas les valeurs
judéo chrétiennes à laquelle il adhère
mais en même temps ceux qui le
soutiennent vont faire appel à des
exemples qu'on retrouve par exemple dans
les piles des exemples de leader par
exemple politique comme le roi perse
cyrus le grand qui a rugi au 6e siècle
donna comme quoi dieu s'est servie de
cyrus impôts me lie le peuple juif de sa
captivité apaisés condiments mais dieu
est en mesure de se servir de leader qui
choisit et c'est pour ça qu'il parle de
tram comme étant un milieu de l'année
lutte
bah oui les lidar que dieu se choisit
malgré le fait qu'ils sont imparfaits
dieu peut se servir de n'importe qui et
on légitime insu un peu ses soutiens
dans mon gendre parce qu'on dit mais
voyez vous dans les vieux c'est celui
d'être un parfait pour accomplir sa
volonté
alors selon vos prédictions vous qui
avait analysé le l'affluence des
évangéliques sur la politique américain
je sais qu'on n'est pas en sciences
politiques on ne ment pas on est dans
l'analyse de ces mouvements est ce que
vous prévoyez que une réélection du
président seront mardi prochain écoutez
c'est d'ici là c'est certain
si on se fie
aux sondages ça semble pas être le corps
mais je me méfie beaucoup des sondages
parce que si vous vous rappelez en 2016
au milieu du mois d'octobre
on disait que le riz clinton allait
gagner l'élection à 91 pour ça il faut
faire très attention vous savez ce bloc
d'évangéliques qui soutiennent trempe
appartiennent à la droite religieuse aux
états unis qui a une capacité de
mobilisation absolument phénoménale de
par les réseaux les pasteurs les
contacts divers qu ils seront onze ans
qu'ils ont entretenue pendant des années
et c'est pour cela ce n'est pas encore
bien unique pour le candidat par dean
malheureusement il va falloir attendre
les résultats des élections
merci andré gagné je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur au département d'études
théologiques à l'université concordia
montréal et vous êtes l'auteur du livre
ces évangéliques derrière tron merci
beaucoup pour avoir accepté notre
invitation
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation